Merhabalar ben Hakan diniz endüstri
ürünleri tasarımcısıyım ama çoğunuz beni
tasarladığım oyun ve oyuncaklardan daha
genç arkadaşlara verdiğimiz oyun oyuncak
tasarımı workshoplar veya gamification
workshoplar tanıyorlar Ama bugün size
Hani oyun tasarımından bahsetmeyeceğim
daha çok bir oyun tasarımcısının Daha
doğrusu oyun ve oyuncakla ilgilenen bir
tasarımcının hayata dair aydınlanmasında
bahsedeceğim Dolayısıyla arkada monopol
tasarlayacağız diye Heyecanlı bir iki
arkadaş vardı Onlar biraz sakin
olabilirler o sonra evet öncelikle bu
aydınlanmanın hani nereden başladığı la
başlayalım umarım sizin için de ilham
verici olacaktır ilham ilham verici
olacaktır Öncelikle burada tasarımcı var
mı acaba Hani konular tasarımsal var
güzel elleri görüyorum E bu cümleyi daha
önce duyduk mu güzel Eee sizin meslek
çok eğlenceli Hani üniversiteden beri
öğrenciliğim bir yılından beri sürekli
duyduğum bir şey sizin meslek çok
eğlenceli Merhaba ben Hakan diniz
endüstri t a sizin meslek çok eğlenceli
Evet Hani şimdi az evvel bahsettim oyun
oyuncak tasarımcısıyım Hani çoğunuz E
tabii Senin meslek çok eğlenceli diyor E
tabii bu insanların algısıyla ilgili bir
durum Herkes zannediyor ki ben sabah
kalkıyorum Ondan sonra jelibondan masama
oturuyorum ond an Sonra işte pembe
tavşandan bir koltuğum var Onu arkamı
yaslayıp falan böyle
duvara renkli pasteller bir şeyler
çiziyorum Hayat öyle değil hani bu
mesela görüyorsunuz ofis Hani standart
bir ofis Hani tasarımcı Ofisi benim
ofisim gün içinde yaptığımız şeyler son
derece teknik şeyler Hani makinalarla
şunlarla bunlarla uğraşıyorsunuz
efendime söyleyeyim draft açıları
kalıplar kalıpçı detayları ondan sonra
maçal
milimetreleri değil mi hala benim meslek
eğlenceli mi Neyse Eee Hani maketler
Keskin şeyler kimyasallar gırla Ve Ofis
sizin olduğu zaman bir de işin içine
managerial bir level giriyor burada
Mesela ü büyük müşterimiz aynı anda
sipariş verip iş yapmaya çalışırken
dördüncüsü aradığında kendimi yere attım
ve kaza kafama çektim Hani Muzip bir
arkadaşım da elime bir Light saber
vermiş ve fotoğrafını çekmiş Hani
Görüntü biraz flu ama mesaj çok
net şimdi Hani her bize sizin meslek çok
eğlenceli diyen biz artık he diyoruz ve
fakat yakın zamanda izotomi araştırma
şirketinin bir Eee araştırma neticesi
yayınlandı ha tasarım dünyasında olay
oldu mutluymuşuz en mutlu 10 meslek
listesinde Hani bir numara tasarımcı
hani biz bu kadar çileden bahsediyoruz
Ben ben mutluyum o zaman hani
mutluymuşuz mutluymuşuz güzel Eee şimdi
burada o üçüncü göz açıldı bir bakın
Yani neden Biz hani en mutlu ve en
mutsuz meslekleri yan yana koyduğumuzda
biz neden bu kadar mutluyuz hani en
mutsuz Bu arada meslekte avukattır Hani
hiçbir mesleğe ymek istemiyorum Bu arada
konu o değil ama hani bir netice var
ortada mutlu meslek mutsuz meslek
finansal getirisine maddi getirisine
baktığımız zaman iki mesleğin Aslında
Avukat tasarımcıdan çok önde Hani iş
imkanı iş garantisi toplumdaki saygınlık
efendime söyleyeyim Hani maddi kazanç
çalışma şartları avukatlık hep önde ve
fakat mutlu olan
biziz değil mi Benim teorim şu birinci
teorim çok kullandığımız kimyasallar ve
boyalar kafa
yapıyor bu bir Bu bir Bu
bir Hani Umarım yapmıyordur Neyse e
ikinci kısmı para Saadet getirmiyor oyun
getiriyor Teşekkürler şimdi şu var Biz
tasarımcılar olarak yaratıcılıkla
ilgilendiğimiz için sürekli bir şeyler
keşfetmeye çalıştığımız için aslında
mesleğimizin içine oyun gayet
yerleştirilmiş vaziyette Biz oyun oynama
hürriyeti olan insanlarız Evet Avukat
kadar para kazanmıyoruz vesaire ama
tatmini Bu yüzden biraz daha yüksek gibi
geliyor şimdi bunu Tabii bu orta sınıf
seviyesinde söylüyorum Lütfen Hani
kafama mazlovun ihtiyaçlar piramidini
atmayın hani belirli bir seviyenin
üstünden bahsediyorum ben burada oyun
paradan önemlidir diye Mesela şöyle
bakalım Hani e küçü bu bir deney Ben
bunu başka sunumlarda yaptım çalışıyor
burada biraz daha ciddi bir Eee kitle
var o yüzden çalışır mı bilmiyorum risk
alıyorum eleman aranıyor 18 yaş üstü
herhangi bir eğitim seviyesinde
kalifikasyon peşinde değilim takım
çalışmasına yatkın sırtında ağır yük
taşıyabilecek 6080 kilo sakatlanma
riskini göze alan banko s katlanacaksın
samimi çalışma ortamını seven ter kokusu
minimum daha da
peki dışarıya çıkacağız birazdan Benimle
uzun eşek kim oynar uzun eşek
oynayacağız Hani eller çok güzel çok
güzel çok güzel çok güzel bayağı bir
eğlenceli aktif bir ruh var burada
arkadaşlar Az önce üste para verdim
benim Hani iş ilanımı kabul
etmediniz O bahsettiğim şey uzun eşekli
İşte bu arada sakatlanma ihtimali Hani
ben şahsen Uzun eşek oynarken bir
ayağımın a arkadaşımın ayağını kırdım
platin takıldı Hani ciddiyim ama eğlence
oldu mu yapılıyor şimdi yine aynı şey bu
bence biraz bize Tabii klinik bir deney
değil ama en azından oyunun paradan
tatminin daha yüksek olduğunu
maddiyattan daha yüksek olduğunu
söylüyor Bence Peki diyeceksiniz ki
Hakan Tamam sen oyun oyuncakla
uğraşıyorsun çocuk ruhlusun çok güzel
ama biz 8 yaşımızı geçeli bayağı oldu
hani çocuk oyun aktivitesi değil mi
Değil Amerikalı psikolog stuart Brown
gerçekten okumanızı hani biraz
Araştırmanızı tavsiye
ederim oyun ve oyuncağın sadece Pardon
oyunun bir çocuk aktivitesi ol
olmadığını bir erişkin aktivitesi de
olması gerektiğini Aslında olduğunu ve
hatta videoya bakalım lütfen kompleks
beyinli bütün canlıların Oyun oynadığını
burada bir karga görüyorsunuz bulduğu
bir kavanoz kapağıyla kızak yapan bir
karga görüyorsunuz bakın karga oyun
oynuyor Hani ve kış günü dikkatinizi
çekerim bakın Hani bir hayvanın temel
gereksinimlerinin yemek ve kendini sıcak
tutmak üremek vesaire olduğunu
düşünürsünüz Ama bakın oyun bir ihtiyaç
ve bu hayvan bunu yapıyor şu anda
bazılarımız gerçekten daha özgür bu
hayvan
inanılmaz video çok sevimli ama sürem
sınırlı devam ediyorum
Eee Peki neden böyle bir algı var
maalesef Ben de eğitim sistemini yere
vuracağım birazdan hazır olun e sebebi
şu
Biz eğitim sistemimizde oyunsuz
laştıramadıklarımızdan var bunun 40
dakikası ciddi 10 dakikası oyun ilk kez
hani bütün gün oyun oynayan çocuklar
birdenbire bir ortama giriyor ve 40
dakika ciddi olmak zorunda o kadar ciddi
olmak zorunda ki elleri falan
bağlıyorlar Hani bayağı deli gömleği
hareketi ve eğitim sistemi devam ettikçe
bu oyuna harcadığınız süre akut olarak
sıfıra kadar iniyor Hani eğitim sistemi
işini bitirdiğinde Siz üniversiteden
çıktığınızda ideal bir bireyin oyun
dakika süresi sı
korkunç yine teorisine göre Sırf bu
yüzden hani biz oyun ve işi Aslında zıt
kelimeler olarak alıyoruz yani oyun
oynama kelimesinin zıttı çalışmak
çalışmak kelimesinin zıttı oyun oynamak
bu korkunç bir
şey Çünkü yine stuart brown'un teorisi
çok güzel gerçekten hani dolduruyor her
şeyi oyun oynamak kelimesinin aslına
bakarsanız Hani zıttı sıkıntı çalışmak
değil sıkıntı sıkıntı sözcüğüne biraz
odaklanın dünyada sıkılan tek
hayvan Hani bu adam değil şahsına münas
değil Ama
insanoğlu Dünya üzerinde sıkılan tek bir
hayvan tek bir canlı türü var insanoğlu
Başka da yok bu korkunç bir şey Bir de
Bazı hayvanlar
sıkılabilen oyun imkanı alınmış
hayvanlar sıkıntı depresyon emareleri
gösteriyor sıkıntı bir insan
icadı inanılmaz bir şey uygarlığın
kirlilik gibi efendime söyleyeyim
yarattığı böyle by product lardan biri
ve hayattan oyunu çıkardığınızda Geride
kalan şey depresyon
sıkıntı Şimdi bunu formülize edelim 24
saatimiz var mesela hayatımızda işte
günlük 8 saati iş 8 saa uyku 8 saati
kişisel bu 8 saatlik iş kısmını aslına
bakarsanız ben şöyle görüyorum oyunsuz
dönem 8 saat oyunsuz luk 8 saat oyunsuz
luk 8 saat depresyon dinlenme kısmı ve
öbür 8 saatte de sıkıntıdan kurtulmaya
arıyorsunuz işte hobi denilen şey burada
da
doğuyor sevmeyerek yaptığınız işten para
kazanıyorsunuz sonra severek yaptığınız
şeye yatırıyorsunuz ya Bu ikisi bir
arada olmuyor mu O işte bu yüzden
hobidir vesairedir Yaşam koçdur böyle
şeylerle böyle hani bütün zamanınızı
geçirmeye başlıyorsunuz
Teşekkürler O zaman diyoruz formül net
oyunsuz luk eşittir sıkıntı İsa o zaman
oyun geri gelmeli oyun geri gelirse
sıkıntı çözülür Peki diyeceksiniz ki e
Hakan tasarımcısın hani eğlenceli pembe
ofis vesaire falan filan eğleniyorsun
Ben noterde bilmem nerede çalışıyorum O
Avukat benim en mutsuz adam benim benim
mesleğime uyarlanır mı bu olmaz o iş
derseniz olur Bakın Rico medellin diye
bir adam var bu mih chiken mihai diye
bir e Macar psikiyatristin e akış
teorisi diye bir eseri var Herkese
tavsiye ederim Tekrar e Rico medellin
çok özel bir insan bu adam bir fabrikada
çalışıyor montaj yapıyor önüne bir parça
geliyor 43 saniyede montajı yapıyor ve
diğer parça geliyor 43 saniye 43 saniye
bunu günde 600 kere yapıyor bundan daha
sıkıcı işi olan olamaz ve Fakat bu adam
özel bir insan Çünkü Normalde 23 ayda bu
Şahıslar değiştirilirken bu işi yapanlar
Rom medim 5 yıla aşkın süredir yapıyor
sorduğunuz zaman televizyon seyretmekten
daha eğlenceli
diyor Neden Çünkü olayı oyuna çevirmiş
kendi kendine hedefler koymuş daha hızlı
nasıl yapabilirim teknikler geliştiriyor
onu yapıyor bunu yapıyor kişisel
süresini 27 saniyeye kadar düşürmüş
patronları istediği için değil daha
fazla para verildiği için değil hani
tamamen kapitalizmin kölesi olduğu için
değil kendisi için yapıyor Adam ve
seviyor işte oyun Aslında elimizde böyle
bir kalkan inanılmaz bir sihirli değnek
oyunun Gücü bu Hani bunu ilk kez Ben
söylemiyorum hepiniz fark etmişsinizdir
Google'ın mesela o inanılmaz Ofisi
YouTube'un Bilişim sektörünün
ofislerinin bir sebebi var adamlar
şanımız yürüsün diye oraya o kaydırağı
koymuyor Hani gerçekten bir fikir
sahibiler Peki bu hani bana değil ricom
medeniye değil Siz de kendinize
uygulayabilir misiniz uygularsınız ideas
into Action hani biz mesela kendi
ofisimizde kullandığımız birkaç metodu
yaptığımız bir iki ürünü birazdan
sizinle paylaşacağım mesela hani oyunu
Jessie Shell şöyle tanımlıyor kendi
iradenize dahil olduğunuz net amaçları
olan rekabet unsuru içeren kuralları
olan belli bir meydan okuma unsuru olan
bunları bir araya getirip kendi süreçler
hayatınızda yerleştirdiğiniz zaman
Pekala oyunsallık
mesela brainstorming ofisimizde hani
tasarım Ofisi sık sık brainstorming
yapılıyor Biz bunu oyun haline getirdik
ortaya bir kova koyuyoruz Çalışanların
hepsi arkadaşlarımın hepsi diziliyor
hepimizin önünde renkli kağıtlar var
fikirlerimizi yazıp yazıp top yapıp
atıyoruz içeriye basket oyunu
içerideki kimin en fazla Fikri varsa
atılan her içerideki fikir başına bir
puan kazanıyoruz ve analiz edip
baktığımızda en iyi fikrin sahibi olan
30 puan kazanıyor ve o hafta ofisin
Kralı Evet çayı kahvesi ayağına geliyor
inanılmaz Mahmut MDM oyunu hani bu bunu
Bunu herkes bilmeyebilir şimdi Mahmut
mm' referansını vereyim Çiçek Abbas
filminden onu da tavsiye ederim onu da
edeyim e Mahmut mu diyen ofis içerisinde
her türlü sunumda toplantıda Biz negatif
sözcükleri Mahmut kelimesiyle
değiştirdik Mesela bir sunum yapılıyor
Hakan Bey Evet işte sundun vesaire
mesela birazdan bana diyecekler Hakan
sunum iyiydi ama Eller kollar çok
Mahmut Hani
e mesela negatif bir şey burada hemen Ne
yapıyoruz kapatıyoruz en Bu arada en az
Mahmut diyen de oyunu kazanıyor ille
Ofiste mi olması lazım Öbür 8 saatte Hiç
mi sıkıcı bir şey yok hayatınızda Tabii
ki var temizlik mesela neden bulaşık
yıkama ve durulama bir yarış olmasın iki
kişi arasında neden ev silme süpürme
arasında bir yarış olmasın Hani bir
yanda paspas bir yanda elektrik
süpürgesi Go yarış size olabilir veya
çocuğunuza aileler için bir ipucu
çocuğunuza diş fırçalamayı öğretmekte
zorlanıyor musunuz oyun haline getirin
çocuğunuzun en sevdiği şarkıyı bulun
Hani belki her akşam yeni şarkı
takacaksınız ve ekran karşısında kare
yoke yapın Pardon ayna karşısında
dişlerinizi fırçalarken kare yoke yapın
yani emin olun çocuğunuzun üzerinde
gerçekten daha pozitif bir etkisi
olacaktır nane tadından daha
iyi Bizim yaptığımız bir üründen
bahsetmek istiyorum hani Action olarak
bu sefer bir Hardware ürün
tasarımcısıyım Çünkü mesela çağımızın en
büyük sıkıntılarından biri artık
oturarak yapılan aktivitelerin çok
cezbedici olması ve çocukların bunları
daha çok tercih ediyor olması ekran
karşısında Hani obezite Kısacası Mesela
biz bununla mücadele edebilmek için
Mesela bir aparat tasarladık Bu bir e
Aslında Action Counter çocuğun hareket
miktarını ölçebiliyor ve günlük olarak
çocuğa kota veriyor hani şu kadar
hareket etmen lazım şu kadar bit şu
kadar aksiyon yapman lazım diye Bu parça
bilekte de olabilir hani hareket leriniz
de vesaire ben yapsam çok ilerlemişti
kol sürekli oynuyor Neyse Eee mesela
bunu çıkartıp Pekala ayağınıza takıp
çevirebilen bir başka aparata
takabiliyor musunuz çıkartıp Hull up'a
takabiliyor musunuz ve Neticede çocuk
günlük olarak bir aksiyon kotası
dolduruyor yapmaya çalıştığımız şey
burada egzersiz ve dışarıya çıkmaya
hareket etmeyi çok sevmeyen çocukları
biraz gamification oyunsallık Eee
aktiviteye sevk etmeye çalışmak netice
olarak eee tekrar başa sarıyorum Hani
sıkıntıya odaklanalım tekrar şunu un
gerçekten hani hayatınızın kaçta kaçını
sıkıntı ve sıkılma halinde geçirdiğinizi
düşünün ve şunu hatırlayın gerçekten
sıkıntı dediğimiz şey bir insan icadı
yok ve tamamen ciddiyetten
kaynaklanıyor O yüzden size diyorum ki
bu kadar ciddi
olmayın Gerçekten bu kadar sıkılmayın
oyuncu olun Kendinize iyi bakın
[Alkış]
teşekkürler